suzanna
as you heard i am incredibly passionate
about this responsible ai space and i'm
really excited to be
working on building tools that make it
easier for data scientists for ml
development teams and for non-technical
stakeholders to engage in the
responsible ai development process
i'm going to guess that you all are here
because you feel similarly you probably
have also seen
a lot of things go wrong with production
aiml systems um
you know it's a gnarly world out there
when when you get into production and a
lot can can go wrong a lot of risk
needs to be managed so what we're going
to do for the next 40 minutes is really
talk about the first of all what is
responsible ai how can we
define and measure the characteristics
the features that make an ai system
responsible
and then what i want to do is actually
give you some really tactical steps that
you can start to do throughout your
development life cycle from you know
inception of an idea all the way through
to putting your system into production
and monitoring it in an ongoing fashion
if at any point in the talk you want to
tweet at me feel free my handle is sh
shattuck
so
i think the first thing that i want to
get out of the way is the fact that
there are a lot of different terms being
thrown around there's a lot of buzzword
bingo when it comes to the responsible
ai space
i'm very intentionally using the words
responsible ai because i actually really
prefer the concrete
description of responsibility that we
have as aiml system developers versus
more fuzzy terms like ai efix
or ai principles
i think there are a lot of different
definitions out there in the market
there are a lot of frameworks there are
a lot of organizations that are talking
about responsible ai ai governance
ethical ai and meaning very different
things and this is actually i think one
of the biggest problems in this space
right now the lack of consensus of
standardized understanding
and standardized processes and so one of
the key things that i'm really
passionate about and that we're trying
to do at credo ai is come up with a
standard framework and process for us to
use when we're thinking about evaluating
whether or not a system is responsible
so one of the things i promised in the
talk abstract right was that i'm going
to move beyond buzzword bingo i'm sorry
i haven't done a very good job of that
yet we've already thrown around words
like ml ops and responsible ai i'm going
to do better
but in all seriousness i think this is
something that we all need to address as
a technical community as well is coming
up with a standardized understanding of
this concept
so what is responsible ai
well the good news is that there is
a fair amount of consensus on sort of
the high level
definition the high level uh features or
characteristics
what i'm calling tenants here of a
responsible ai system so at a high level
a responsible ai system is fair
transparent safe and secure privacy
preserving does not inflict a lot of
social or environmental harm
and has the right accountability
structures in place
so you may be thinking okay that all
sounds nice but what does that actually
mean and how the heck do i
operationalize this in my development
life cycle
so i would like for us to move from
thinking about these high level concepts
to thinking about these as measurable
actionable things
i want us as a data science community to
be able to measure every single one of
these features
both of our models and our data sets the
technical assets that we're creating but
also our processes and the people
involved in the ml development life
cycle and so i'll spend a little bit of
time on this slide actually going
through and talking about the ways that
we are currently able to measure these
different features
um and i'll go through these from sort
of most measurable most well
operationalized to least measurable and
most vague and throughout this talk i'm
going to be talking about areas of
active research where more work needs to
be done um so i i do want to make sure
that we're all coming to this
conversation with the understanding that
this is not a solved problem in any way
shape or form right and so in many ways
this is a call to action for us to
continue to come up with better ways to
measure these um and i'll be in the
office hours room across the way if you
want to have more conversations about
that in greater detail 40 minutes is not
enough time
to really go into all of that but let's
start with fairness
so how do we measure fairness this is
probably the most well operationalized
responsible ai tenant um there are a lot
of existing open source frameworks and
tools that lay out some very effective
ways of measuring the fairness of an
aiml system and there are two key
dimensions to fairness that need to be
measured parity of outcomes
and parity of performance
and which dimension
that matters most for your use case is
highly use case and context dependent
i'll give you an example if you have a
hiring system we were just in the front
row talking about uh ai hiring systems
you care about parity of outcomes
because you don't want a system that
violates what's known in hr as the four
fifths rule the rule that you should be
hiring minority candidates at a rate
that is at least 80 percent of the rate
at which you're hiring majority
candidates
so you want to make sure that the
outcomes that your system is delivering
are
fairly equal across different groups
that are interacting with your system
you want a system that hires
black people at a rate that is fairly
equal to the rate at which it hires
white people for example
now a cancer detection system
very different you do not care about
parity of outcomes you do not want to
predict that black people have cancer at
the same rate that white people do you
want to predict at the same accuracy
level across all groups because the most
important thing for that system is for
it to be accurate to deliver an accurate
diagnosis
so for that kind of system parity of
performance is the key dimension with
which you measure fairness
so that that's a brief discussion of
fairness but that's an example i think
of a pretty well operationalized
responsible ai tenant we have an
understanding of how to measure
dimensions of fairness that we care
about we have metrics
we have tools
that exist and and have been well proven
in industry to measure these things now
fairness is still a critical concern
that i think a lot of organizations
aren't properly taking into account i'm
by no means saying this is solved
but we want to get to the same place
that we're in with fairness with all of
these other principles all of these
other tenets
we want to be able to say these are the
specific metrics or the specific
technical characteristics and behavior
that we can measure to prove that a
system is transparent enough to prove
that a system is safe and secure enough
etc
so moving down the list
transparency
is not just explainability i think a lot
of people use those terms
interchangeably transparency is really
about how well do people understand
what your ai system does and how it does
it and so explainability is a critical
piece right understanding how specific
feature inputs contribute to specific
outputs that's great but there are a lot
of other
unsexy characteristics of transparency
that are equally important things like
disclosure do the people interacting
with your ai system understand that it
is an ai system do they understand what
outputs that system is going to be
providing
documentation
is there reasonable documentation
available to the people interacting with
your system so they can understand how
it works i think a lot of companies you
know say raise up their hands and say oh
we'd love to be transparent but we have
to protect our ip we can't expose you
know our individual feature weights
and i think it's really important for us
to think about evaluating and measuring
a much fuller picture of transparency
than just exposing the complete inner
workings of an individual model or or ai
system
safety and security are very well solved
areas for other technologies for
software for robotics
less well solved for ai specific safety
and security concerns
and so this is an area where there are
emerging ways to measure things like
adversarial robustness
but there's a lot more work that needs
to be done in this space
so one of the things that we do at creto
ai is we try to pull in all of the best
open source frameworks or approaches
from academia for measuring these things
and we operationalize them in an open
source assessment framework which i'll
be talking about at the very end of my
presentation
and
we are seeing that there are more and
more open source projects related to
assessing safety and security of ai
systems so i'm excited by the movement
that i see in this space but there's
definitely a lot more work that needs to
be done to turn this into something
truly measurable
in a concrete way and the same holds
true for privacy there are more and more
open source privacy
ai specific frameworks
now i do think that there's a lot of
work that is important for responsible
ai that happens at the data set level
but when it comes to privacy there has
not been enough work at the model level
really understanding things like
the possibility of data leakage
particularly in these large generative
models that are increasingly popular so
coming up with ways to measure how
privacy preserving not only your data
set and data set processes and practices
are is critical
but also how privacy preserving is the
actual model that you're delivering in
production
okay now we come to the two like big
elephants in the room right social and
environmental well-being and
accountability how the heck do you
measure these things
so these are by far the the two sort of
least measurable tenants of responsible
ai in this space
but we're working on changing that so
social and environmental well-being i
like to think of as
what are the negative real world
feedback loops
that your system could cause
and how are we going to prevent those
feedback loops how are we going to stop
them a great example
are content recommendation systems that
trap people in content bubbles
that is a very damaging real world
negative feedback loop
that was not accounted for
in the design and development of those
systems
and so i actually think that the most
measurable thing that we can look at
right now to understand this tenet of
responsible ai is
have you asked questions about what your
potential negative feedback loops are
and do you have mitigation plans in
place for the ones that you've uncovered
and and we'll talk a lot more about the
actual process of doing that i think one
of the reasons why this is such a hard
nut to crack in a measurable way is that
it's an incredibly multi-disciplinary
problem
you cannot answer this pro this question
with just technical data technical
information alone
and that's actually one of the reasons
why i've moved away from the mlops and
ml monitoring space to think more
holistically about ai governance because
i think if we get too stuck in just
thinking about the technical aspects of
our systems we lose sight of the forest
through the trees we lose
this core tenet of responsible ai
okay and then lastly accountability how
do we measure
accountability of our ai development
process
so this is really all about
understanding who is accountable at
every decision point in your process
and making sure that you have an
auditable record of those decisions that
you can go back to
to understand if something does go wrong
or if something goes in a way that you
didn't expect
tracing back that decision to say hey
this is what we thought was going to
happen let's make sure that we do that
differently in the future so
accountability
i like to think of as more of something
that we measure in our process rather
than we measure in our models um but
that this is an emerging space that a
lot of regulators are also paying
attention to when it comes to things
like legal liability you know if a
self-driving car hits somebody the
famous trolley problem who's at fault um
i i'm thinking more about accountability
in this talk as the process
accountability than that legal liability
but that's an important dimension as
well that i wanted to
mention
so i know this is a lot we have six new
things that we need to measure
at every step of the development life
cycle
so how are we actually going to do that
well i am going to now share with you
what i have seen work well at the
customers that i've worked with that are
trying to implement responsible ai
practices uh you really need to
integrate this into your development
life cycle and this is the way that a
lot of companies start
they have the normal ai development life
cycle right
this all looks familiar
and they add an extra step
probably right before the model is
deployed some kind of responsible ai
check-in or risk and compliance review
and look if you're doing things like
this
you're doing a responsible ai check-in
like that's great i'm excited but we can
do better
because this is actually
almost guaranteed to give you bad
outcomes to not deliver on your goals of
actually building responsible ai systems
let me explain why this has everything
to do with incentive alignment
so at this point in the development life
cycle there are a lot of decisions that
have already been made there is a lot of
money that has probably already been
spent there is a lot of time that has
already been spent you've gone through
the effort of procuring a training data
set that was probably painful you've
gone through the process of
experimentation building a model you
finally found one that meets your
performance requirements
that was probably painful
you even picked a use case right that's
that's a sort of implicit step in the
development life cycle you decided to
apply aiml to something
all of those decisions are very
difficult to walk back on at this point
in the life cycle where you're about to
deploy
the team that worked on this thing is
very excited to launch they're so close
to getting their work into production
they are not going to be excited about
this responsible ai check-in they are
going to see this as a blocker and let
me tell you we work with a lot of newly
formed ai oversight or ai governance
teams at our credo ai customers and
almost all of them say the same thing to
me when we start working together they
say susanna i am desperate to be seen as
a business enabler not a business
blocker
how can you help me
and the first thing i tell them is that
if they're doing their governance
process like this i can't help them they
are going to be seen as a blocker
so the way to get out of this trap where
you
can't really achieve much by doing your
responsible ai check-in at this step you
can't really walk back on a lot of those
decisions
is to instead integrate these check-ins
these moments of assessment and
measurement
throughout the development life cycle at
every single step
and this is completely transformative
for the culture of a development team
i've seen development teams transform
the way they work by doing this
they go from being reactive about
responsible ai issues that end up you
know being sticking points right before
they go into production to being
proactive
to actually having moments where they
are being asked to consider what might
go wrong with this system rather than
just responding to the things that go
wrong and the other amazing thing about
doing it like this is that you actually
reduce the burden of responsible ai
check-ins and assessment by spreading it
out over a much longer time scale and
doing discrete types of assessments at
different moments in time whereas before
it was this incredibly arduous process
that i kid you not at some of our
customers this responsible ai check-in
results in a 50-page
confluence document that somebody has to
go through and read and review that is
an incredibly arduous process
to being something that happens
at one hour intervals across the many
months that you're working on this
project um so i
if there's one thing that you take away
from this talk
right it's that if you're thinking about
doing responsible ai assessment if
you're thinking about adopting a
responsible ai development process
you need to do it throughout it cannot
be a single moment in time that you're
doing that check-in
now you might wonder like what what does
the check-in look like across all of
these different moments um so this this
is a rough map right this is the the
template that we suggest um there are a
lot of different ways to do this but
the rough guide is that at the very
beginning when somebody whether it's the
ceo of your company or the vp of sales
or whoever when they have an idea and
they say go apply ai to this problem
that triggers the first responsible ai
assessment which is a use case review
which is all about thinking through the
unintended consequences of applying aiml
to that problem
and this is the best moment
to bring in
a multi-stakeholder diverse team to sit
down and talk through those consequences
and the result of that use case review
is going to be that you have a list of
potential harms
that is your roadmap
for your responsible ai development
process throughout the development
process
you should be making sure that you are
mitigating every single one of those
harms
and so that comes to the next step
which we call alignment at credo ai this
is about defining the specific
requirements the responsible ai
requirements that your system must meet
in the exact same way that you have
business requirements performance
requirements cost requirements
you need to have fairness requirements
transparency requirements security
requirements etc
and this step will give you the specific
roadmap for how you're going to measure
and assess each of those tenants
during your uh training and development
and so that's when you actually move
into using tools like ai fairness 360 or
microsoft's responsible ai toolkit or
our open source framework credo ai lens
to run assessments run technical
assessments on your models and your data
sets
and if you've done all of that
then by the time you get to that
validation step before going into
deployment
you're pretty confident that your system
is going to meet that set of
requirements you've been testing all
along and so at this point the risk and
compliance review isn't a blocker
it's a validation of all of the hard
work that you've already put in and it
can happen a lot faster
you probably aren't going to uncover
some huge catastrophic risk that causes
you to go back to the drawing board and
it's it's a much easier process if
you've been doing all that hard work up
front
but of course we all know
with machine learning systems it doesn't
end there you have to continue to manage
and monitor responsible ai features of
your system in production in the exact
same way that you have to continue to
monitor and manage performance
and so when you deploy that's when you
need to be giving all of your
documentation your disclosure assets to
everybody who's going to be impacted by
that system
and then you need to conduct ongoing
responsible ai audits and monitor for
responsible ai features or metrics in
production
easy right that's that's it
you you're doing responsible ai if you
do this um
if only it were that easy right i i
think uh
a lot of organizations are recognizing
that they need to move in this direction
but it's painful because it slows you
down
and i want to be very upfront about that
it will slow you down a little bit
and one of the things that we are trying
to do at credo ai is to make this
process less
friction filled to make it easier to
reduce the cost quote unquote of doing
this process the right way
so that it's a no-brainer right so that
it's so obvious that
there's no reason why you wouldn't um
and so what i'm going to talk about now
are the specific things that you should
do
to achieve this
end goal of having responsible ai
assessment incorporated into your entire
development life cycle
so the tldr from from that section of
the talk the end of part one uh you know
during design during development and
during deployment there are specific
responsible ai things that you need to
do
and the most most most important point
that i want to hammer home is that this
is not something that a data science
team that a technical team can or should
do alone this is a multi-stakeholder
multi-disciplinary problem there are a
lot of really hard questions that you're
going to have to answer during this
process and you need to be bringing in
not only diverse stakeholders from your
own organization but also from
from regulators from uh you know
impacted populations um you need to be
getting a diverse set of perspectives to
solve these problems
great
so now let's go into the tactical part
of the conversation i want to share with
you across the design phase the
development phase and the deployment
phase some specific things that you can
and should do to make sure that your
systems are responsible
so the use case review at the beginning
and the
defining and aligning on responsible ai
metrics your technical responsible ai
assessment plan
is
by far the hardest step of this process
and it's really hard because again it's
requiring you to
imagine
what the potential risks of your system
are
and then think about how to mitigate
those risks
and so we at credo ai have developed a
set of questions that we encourage our
customers to ask themselves
in this phase to do that most
effectively and these questions really
center around who what and how
who is going to be impacted by your ai
system
what is the ai system going to do for
or to these people
and how are you going to mitigate those
potential impacts mitigate or encourage
right if it's a benefit then you want to
make sure that the system does it if
it's a harm you want to mitigate
and so we really encourage people to
think broadly here about the who not
just the direct users of your system but
also the indirect users i'll call back
to my cancer detection system example
the you know direct directly impacted
person is the patient they're the one
who's being predicted to have cancer or
not they are a critical stakeholder
but you also have the doctors who are
probably the actual users of the system
they're the ones who probably receive
the recommendation from from your model
about whether or not their patient has
their patient has cancer you need to
consider
what their needs are and and what the
impacts on their work are as you're
evaluating the impact of your system
and i'll give you an example trust is
something that's really critical in
healthcare systems because if your
doctor doesn't trust the output of your
cancer detection model they're probably
not going to go and and give that
diagnosis they're going to want to run
the analysis themselves which might be
more expensive more time consuming less
accurate so in addition to having to
manage the accuracy and performance and
fairness for the patient you need to
manage trust for the doctor
another great way to think about
potential harms is by looking at the
regulatory environment that your use
case will be operating in because
regulations are
designed and this might be a
controversial statement but i believe
the regulations are usually designed to
mitigate harm they're designed to
address some kind of negative impact
that has been uncovered in the world
and so if you look to your regulatory
environment you will get actually a
pretty good guide of some of the really
critical harms that need to be addressed
like hipaa in the context of healthcare
is a very good guide for understanding
what are all the ways in which patient
data could be mishandled or misused
that should be your guide for thinking
about how privacy preserving your cancer
detection system needs to be for example
and then the last piece
how do we measure and mitigate negative
impacts
this is really all about translating
those harms that you've
uncovered into actual metrics things
that you can test for and things that
you can make sure that you're mitigating
during your development life cycle and
that translation of harms to metrics
is really difficult so that's where um
there are a set of tools that are being
developed and
these tools range from open source tools
like the akitas framework which helps
you understand how to actually define
and measure fairness for a given use
case highly recommend checking it out if
you haven't
industry standards and benchmarks right
those help you define what good looks
like we still have a long way to go with
this but organizations like nist are
starting to chip away at this work
and then tools like credo ai are
designed to help you do that translation
from potential harms to metrics so again
i'll be in the room across the way if
you want to learn anything more about
that and what we're doing but this
responsible ai alignment step is is
really really hard and you all should be
leveraging as many tools as you can in
this process to make sure that you're
doing it the right way
so that's designing
what about when we actually go into
development
so development is all about figuring out
what model
best fits my constraints right and the
normal constraints
the constraints for the last many years
have been usually performance and cost
right what's the most performant model
that i can make that meets my cost
limitations
responsible ai metrics
further constrain your problem space
so it's not just about what's the most
performant model that i can build at the
right price point it's about what is the
most performant model that is also
meeting my fairness constraints my
transparency constraints my privacy
constraints etc
and i think that this is a really
important thing for data scientists and
ml engineers to understand is you have
to really incorporate these metrics
into the trade-off decisions that you're
making about the best models to pick
which means that this can't be something
that happens at the end like this just
further validates the fact that you need
to be measuring these aspects of your
system
all along the way um you need to be
incorporating fairness metrics into your
objective function you need to be
incorporating robustness metrics into
your objective function
the other key thing to remember is that
it's not just about your models you also
need to be assessing your data
it's actually a lot cheaper and easier
to solve responsible ai problems by
solving them in the data then solving
them in the model if you have bias data
if you have data that is not correctly
privacy preserving it's going to be a
lot harder to fix the resulting biased
or
not privacy preserving model than it is
to just go back to the data and
fix the problems there
the other key thing that you can do
during development which reduces a lot
of the challenges that we have around
models not actually making it into
production and being really expensive a
total waste of time and money to develop
rule out model methodologies from the
beginning rule out data sets from the
beginning that don't meet your
requirements
if you identify that explainability is a
core requirement a regulatory
requirement or an end-user requirement
don't use an unexplainable model
type architecture like it's uh it's
again just so critical to do these
things at the beginning to define your
responsible ai requirements at the
beginning
because that will save you a lot of
wasted time and effort
then the last piece i i
am sure i don't have to hammer this home
to all of you in this room you're here
but you need to document everything that
you're doing during the development
process every decision that you're
making not just because it's a good idea
for reproducibility and
all of that but it's critical for
transparency and it's critical for
accountability two of those core tenants
um and so actually one of the things
that we're trying to do at credo ai is
make documentation of responsible ai
features and and development processes
less painful
okay what what about in deployment what
are the things that you need to do in
deployment
monitoring is great
i've worked in the monitoring space for
many years
every company should have machine
learning monitoring in place
if you don't currently we should
probably have a serious chat
performance monitoring that's great
drift monitoring even better
whenever possible
try to monitor responsible ai metrics as
well
fairness monitoring if you have ground
truth um now the challenge with
monitoring
is that ground truth is not always
easily available or if it is it's on a
much longer time scale than your
monitoring is valuable for
so
this is where stress tests and audits
come into play as well for those things
that you do not have access to ground
truth for that are difficult to monitor
for
you should be conducting regular
at least quarterly audits
and a random audit from an independent
team within your organization is also a
really good way to check if your
documentation is good enough
so audits are great for a lot of reasons
but this is something that i think a lot
of organizations
are not doing today they do this
responsible ai check-in once
and then they think all is good we
passed we're all green put it into
production i never have to think about
fairness of this system again
but that is not the case these systems
are learning and changing over time so
we need to make sure that they're
continuing to meet our expectations and
requirements
you also need to make sure that you're
getting non-technical feedback not just
monitoring data and technical audit
results but also
qualitative feedback from your end users
every ai system that is put into
production needs to have some kind of
feedback mechanism uh and this is where
again i think that there's uh uh some
lack of imagination when it comes to
figuring out what are the different ways
to get feedback it's not just about a
customer support channel
there are a lot of great ways to
introduce simple thumbs up thumbs down
you know
tell me more kind of buttons into your
user experience and getting that
feedback is one of the best ways to
identify potential harms that you didn't
think of in the beginning so you need to
be open to that
the last thing
i was a girl scout
be prepared i i'm all about it and you
need to be prepared for things to go
wrong
things will go wrong
even if you do this process
perfectly every single time
there will be issues that arise in
production and a key aspect of the
responsibility in responsible ai is
being responsible for when things go
wrong and having a mitigation plan
having a specific person who's
responsible for implementing that
mitigation plan for responsible ai
issues in production
so i think probably if if you're
anything like um many of the
organizations that i've worked with you
might be sitting there sweating in your
seat because i'm going to guess that
there are a lot of things that i just
talked about that you're not currently
doing
so i i just want to first say
that's normal
very few organizations have truly
operationalized this responsible ai
process that i just described to you
but i think
this is like one of the most pressing
challenges of our time
and and our community's responsibility
is to
get from where we are today where we
don't even know what systems we have in
production in many organizations
to really deeply feeling confident in
the way that our systems are going to
behave in production feeling confident
that they're going to meet our
requirements
so i want to just end and then we'll do
a quick q a with
a quick plug for something that i
mentioned a couple times during the
presentation credo ai lens
so this is in many ways lenses coming
out ceremony uh we have just released
this um
framework into open source so it's
available
and we're very excited for all of you to
try it out
lens is a
responsible ai assessment framework it's
a python based framework
and we very much believe that what you
can't observe you can't control
so lens is designed to help you observe
those six responsible ai tenants that i
described at the beginning of my talk
so that you can make better development
decisions deployment decisions based on
them
and so the way that lens works
it's a combination of a lot of
best-in-class existing open source
libraries like
aif360 microsoft's rye toolkit
as well as additional modules and
capabilities that we've built out
ourselves like data set assessment for
fairness um an nlp model assessment tool
that looks at things like toxicity
and we combine all of these capabilities
into what we call modules
which you can string together
to generate any kind of assessments that
you want and lens will run those
assessments on your models and your data
sets and output these html reports as
well as just a static list of metrics
and the reports have pretty charts in
them and descriptions all of that comes
out of the box and the goal is that lens
is not only a tool that helps a
technical team do these assessments more
efficiently and effectively but also
creates outputs that are legible and
useful
for non-technical teams as well
and so we are very excited to have data
scientists from this event go out and
try this out and we would love to hear
from you about a whether these
assessments are useful for you and b
what the response is from your other
stakeholders when you share with them
the outputs of lens
and so this this slide just has a list
of our current capabilities um
we were pretty specifically focused on
fairness for a while but now we're
expanding to privacy explainability
but we right now have a full suite of
fairness and performance assessments
available um the documentation link is
down below credo ai dash lens dot read
the docs dot io
as i said this is this is our coming out
party so um we're eager for feedback
and if you want to talk more about lens
or
anything that i just shared in this
presentation
again i'll be in the room across the
hall for office hours and i'd love to
hear
from any of you about your current
challenges goals hopes and dreams
related to responsible ai adoption
so with that um thank you so much i am
available now for i think five minutes
of q a
[Applause]